let's think about this function now
what's happening is you ignore and this
kind of came to the fore when we were
doing the graphing topic not that long
ago real functions you know about a
whole bunch of different kinds of
functions and relations as well actually
you know what they look like you know
how to draw them but what would be
introduced aside your like derivatives
of differentiation we've pretty much
stuck to polynomials right we just
started with various importance and
that's because this idea of
differentiation we want to nail at first
we want to nail first principles before
we expand the repertoire before we think
about okay look at all these other
different kinds of functions that you
actually are we're off
I mean fix it and how do we
differentiate those as well so in some
ways in calculus we cut up there playing
catch-up right where we know all of
these kinds of pictures but we don't
know how to differentiate all of them
we're going to do it how to
differentiate it's a little small subset
so we are learning ways of expanding our
repertoire today is a really big one
let's how about think about this
function now if we were to differentiate
y equals 4x squared plus 1 or squared
okay at the moment what were you need to
think of is well I can't look I have a
oh I know how to differentiate x squared
I can do that it's just a it's just a
power of X I know how to do 4x squared
that's just a multiple of a power of X I
don't know how to do one okay but ok but
in order to get this into something that
I can work with like this this being
squared right it's not just a sum or
multiple I need to expand this out in
order to get a sum or multiple so let's
give this a go it's just the perfect
square what let's expand it out 4x
squared a plus B squared is gonna be a
squared plus 2 a B plus B squared right
so what am I gonna get what am I gonna
write down first 16 X to the 4 that's
the a squared then I'm gonna get to a B
in the middle which will be edx sweats
and then there's just gonna be a 1 hey
you in the end you happy with that so
far so good
so if this is why now I've got it afford
that at the moment I can differentiate
now I can actually find the derivative I
could say on this basis
do you wanna be X is equal to and now
these are all just sums and multiples
and we dealt with them yesterday right
so 16 X to the 4 what happens to that 4
up into power it comes out the front
comes multiply that by the coefficient
that's already there and becomes 64 and
then the power goes down by 1 right
important to do it in that order by the
way because you're not gonna multiply by
3 you're gonna pop my for the power that
it was before that's the first term
second term is just gonna become read it
off she was going to come out the foot
become a 16 that's gonna be X to the 1
so I'm done okay and we already know I'm
gonna stop writing because it becomes
weird a trivial thing where you see a
constant differentiating a closely you
can think about it in two ways number
one differentiated cuts that will give
you zero okay or secondly if this was
the function right what is the
difference in gradient between this
function and this function and the
answer is there's no difference this
plus one it just moves the whole thing
up
doesn't contribute anything to the
gradient okay so you can either think of
it in terms of differentiate you get
zero or it doesn't contribute anything
down here to everybody
I can't wait done so this is all happy
times but it doesn't take too much
effort to imagine a point where in order
to differentiate like before we could
even start this differentiating process
we had to expand okay expanding was okay
because the power was low it was just
too squaring we're very good at right if
it was cubed you've done binomial it
could do that it would take a bit more
effort but you could do it okay but as
those powers start to get higher it
starts to become less and less practical
if it was four I think that's really
wrong like I think three tests enough if
it was five you're sort of getting a bit
you know if it was say you know I don't
know 30 you're just gonna say forget it
right I
it would take me half an hour just to
write out the expansion level a
differentiator so we're not going to be
demonstrating any of your skill set
so therefore well we have high powers
like this we need to have better tools
at our disposal than just you know
expanding out and then differentiating
classic stadia and then differentiating
so little bit like you know trying to uh
you've got a you know a be a huge pot of
soup okay you've got like 20 people to
feed and you're trying to feed them
you're trying to label it out every with
a teaspoon you know like I'm just gonna
be here forever right
surely there's a more efficient tool
like a used to just go up and off you go
do the next one okay so here's what we
gonna do let's come back to this guy
right what I see here is that this is
not just one big function I can think of
it as your ever we were thinking about
compound functions yesterday right we
were thinking about what happens when
you add different functions together
what happens when you multiply functions
by numbers okay here what I got is one
function in there 4x squared plus 1
that's a function and then imma play
another function to that I am squaring
the whole thing squaring is a function
yeah
so I've got a function in yeah and then
see that function on the plight another
function I'm squaring it yes